a court in Greece overnight delivered no
murder convictions in the beating death
of an American citizen Bakari Henderson
was 22 years old when a mob chased him
down a street and beat him to death on a
Greek island in July 2017 six men were
convicted on charges of grievous bodily
harm and three others unless her charges
Charlie d'Agata is in London following
the breaking story Charlie good morning
well good morning Vlad the parents of
bukhari Henderson stood in a state of
shock as they heard the verdicts read
out one defendant facing 15 years others
far less three will be walking free
outside the court Henderson's parents
told CBS this morning they were
devastated with the verdict I can't
understand man's life here in Greece
doesn't mean anything you should not be
able to chase a man down and beat him to
death and then not go to jail and serve
jail time until it all became too much
the nine defendants mostly of Serbian
descent claimed they had not intended to
kill Henderson the court agreed the
recent business graduate from the
University of Arizona was in Greece last
year on a working holiday with friends
until that night when he ran into the
defendants at a bar a serb woman told
investigators she posed for a selfie
with the american when a man nearby said
there are a lot of Serbs in the bar why
are you talking to a black guy then
smacked Henderson in the face
Henderson hit back the brawl moved
outside where a mob of men chased him
down the street brutally beating him 30
seconds later 22 year-old Bakari
Henderson was dead in an interview with
CBS this morning's Michelle Miller
before they left for their trial Jill
and Phil Henderson say they believe race
may have played a role in their son
being beaten to death his face was
bruised and swelling to the point where
we put sunglasses on him when we buried
him prosecutors said they will appeal
the verdict Manny meaning it might go to
a higher court the defendants were seen
smiling hugging one another and giving
each other high-fives after the
goes right out Vienna well heartbreaking
news for precarious family charlie thank
you